bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce second des binaires consacrée
aujourd'hui aux bases du langage r alors
le but de la session d'aujourd'hui va
être de reprendre de manière un petit
peu plus formel les bases du langage et
donc la base des différents types
d'objets dans r c'est une session un
petit peu ardu mais qui est vraiment
essentiel pour bien comprendre par la
suite les différents comme on dit que
l'on va aborder et ça va nous permettre
ensuite d'aborder sereinement la semaine
prochaine la statistiques descriptives
notamment avec les package esquisse
editis mari alors comme la semaine
dernière un n'hésitez pas à poser vos
questions dans l'espace de chat youtube
j'essaierai intervalles réguliers de m'y
inscrire pour aller regarder plus
précisément vos questions alors je vous
propose de basculer sur la vue vers
studio que l'on a abordé la semaine
dernière et nous allons tout d'abord
commencé cette cession par revenir sur
les lecteurs
en effet les vecteurs sont l'objet de
base en l'air et il correspond à une
liste de valeurs nous l'avions vu la
semaine dernière et plus spécifiquement
leurs propriétés fondamentales sont les
vecteurs sont des objets unidimensionnel
ils n'ont plus une dimension nous le
verrons un peu plus loin
à la différence d'autres objets comme
les tableaux de données qui vont avoir
plusieurs dimensions
toutes les valeurs d'un vecteur sont un
seul et même type et les acteurs ont une
longueur qui correspond au nombre de
valeurs qui sont contenus dans ce
secteur
alors reprenons ça petit à petit tout
d'abord il faut comprendre qu'il ya
plusieurs types de lecteurs il existe
même au niveau le plus fondamental
quatre grands types de vecteurs les
nombres réels
les nombres entiers les chaînes de
caractères qui correspond à du texte et
valeur logique ou valeur booléenne qui
correspondent aux valeurs ray est faux
et on l'a vu trou ou france en anglais
ce sont les formats fondamentaux de type
de vecteurs on verra par la suite qu'il
y à d'autres types de lecteurs comme les
facteurs que nous aborderons tout à
l'heure mais également des vecteurs de
type date alors pour connaître la nature
d'un objet sous verre à on peut avoir
recours à la fonction classe qui
marchera peu près tous les objets et
notamment sur un vecteur ça va nous
permettre de savoir de quel type de
vecteurs il s'agit si je fais par
exemple classe de 12.5 j'obtiens
numérique et ça me permet de savoir que
l'objet que j'écris 12.5 est un objet
numérique
essayons avec un nombre entier si je
tape classe de 3 alors j'obtiens de
nouveaux numérique
on l'avait vu rapidement la semaine
dernière mais quand on tape un nombre
même s'il s'agit d'un nombre entier
il va être considéré comme entier si on
veut spécifiquement faire un nombre qui
soit un entier et non pas un nombre
flottons c'est à dire un nombre avec une
valeur de signal
il faut rajouter après le 3 le symbole l
majuscule donc 3 elle veut juste dire le
nombre 3 mai codés comme un nombre
entier et non pas comme un nombre
décimal alors à lui sage vous aurez
rarement besoin de ce suffixe 1 heure
arrive très bien dépatouiller avec des
nombres entiers codé sous forme de
nombres décimaux dans certains cas ça
peut être important
retenez sinon si vous voyez un seul l
majuscule
ça signifie entier et pour expliciter
d'où vient arts en fête ce elle sait que
ça vient de l'anglais longue integer
l'intérêt c'est que sur des nombres
entiers très très grand il faut les
stocker sous une forme de nombres
entiers alors que si on les stocke sous
forme de nombres décimaux on aura en
fait que les premiers chiffres mais au
quotidien dans quelles analyses enquêtes
on va rarement
rarement être confronté à ce type de
problème troisième type de vecteurs de
base vous l'avons abordé les vecteurs
textuel nous l'avons vu la semaine
dernière à une valeur textuel syndic
avec des guillemets double par exemple
si je fais classe est entre guillemets
j'indique abc on me dit character et
character et la manière d'indiquer les
valeurs textuel enfin on là je voulais
dire le quatrième grand type de vector
ce sont les valeurs logique qui
s'écrivent fou ou farce et si je fais
face de trous
j'obtiens la valeur l'objectif ont donc
on a vu les quatre grands types de
vecteurs c'est la classe integer pour
les entiers numérique pour les nombres à
réel avec éventuellement donc une partie
des six mal car l'acteur pour les
chaînes de caractères et logic comme
pour les valeurs booléenne par froid
vous pourrez être amené à voir le terme
d'abord plutôt que numérique mais c'est
tout à fait qu'ils valent ans et ça
renvoie en fait ça renvoie un niveau de
précision codage informatique plus
fondamentaux alors nous aborderons un
peu plus tard d'autres types de vecteurs
dans la suite du cours en particulier
aujourd'hui nous allons aborder les
facteurs qui sont la manière sous un air
de coder des variables catégorielles
mais également à des données labellisés
qui ont une classe à qui s'appelle
havane la bounce les vecteurs date une
classe qui s'appelle date
et puis où pourrait aussi avoir des
vecteurs de type date et heure qui sont
la forme posix été et après il existe
tout un tas d'autres types de vecteurs
par exemple pour des données génétiques
pour d'autres types de fonds alors la
première
chose qui va nous intéresser c'est de
créer un vecteur et nous l'avons vu la
semaine dernière pour créer un vecteur
on a tout simplement recours à la
fonction c'est c'est pour qu'on bind
supposons que je veux refaire un vecteur
contient
je vais appeler taillan c'était notre
exemple la semaine dernière il va
compter quatre valeurs 1,88 1,72 un an
66 et 1,75
j'appelle simplement la fonction sais et
je lui vient dit que séparées par des
virgules
les différentes valeurs si je regarde la
classe de ce vecteur on peut faire
classe de taille et j'obtiens numérique
qui me dit comment l'information est
codée
supposons maintenant un deuxième vecteur
qui va contenir le sexe des personnes
que j'ai interrogées
je vais faire un vecteur que j'appelle
sexe et qui va contenir les valeurs h f
f et h
vous aurez remarqué ainsi du texte je
les saisies entre guillemets et si je
regarde classe de sexe
mon vecteurs et de type character enfin
je peux très bien aussi créé un vecteur
à deux types logique par exemple je vais
un vecteur urbain qui me dit c'est les
personnes interrogées habitent en milieu
urbain ou rural
il va valoir choo choo files et cfo et
si je regarde la valeur la classe 1 de
ce vecteur classe de urbain est tout
simplement logique alors
je voulais dit tout à l'heure toutes les
valeurs d'un vecteur doivent être
obligatoirement du même type
un vecteur a comme spécificité que
toutes ces valeurs sont du même type
et donc si j'ai essayé de faire un
vecteur qui mélange plusieurs types
supposons que je fasse un vecteur c'est
un vecteur x avec ses et je lui passe un
nombre entier un nombre décimal une
valeur textuelle et une valeur logique
si je regarde la classe 2 x vous verrez
que tout a été transformé en valeur de
type character combat d'arts textuelle
et si j'affiche x à l'écran en fait
ayrault a converti mais valeur numérique
on va leur texte si j'avais faire je
vais refaire un autre exemple un vecteur
y qui lui va combiner des valeurs par an
r un nid
rick décimales est logique dans ce cas
là la conversion va être un petit peu
différent puisque on va le convertir
simplement en valeur décimales et donc
du coup j'ai un vecteur de classe
numérique
quand on
sion les hantises convertissent tout
simplement en valeur dessine mal et les
valeurs choo et files se convertissent
tout simplement avec 1 0 alors on le
voit on peut facilement créer un vecteur
avec la fonction c'est à sauf que
vouloir combiner créer des vecteurs de
grande taille
s'il faut tout à fait à la main ça
devient rapidement fastidieux alors on
peut facilement lorsqu'on a quelque
chose qui se répète avoir recours à la
fonction rép
si je fais rep 2,10 ça va répéter le
vecteur de 10 fois et je tiens donc un
vecteur avec 10 fois la valeur 2 je peux
aussi lui indiquer plusieurs valeurs qui
seront répétés en boucle par exemple je
voulu passer le vecteur à b et je vais
demander à ce que ce vecteur soit
répétée trois fois et j'obtiens un objet
avec six valeurs qui seront à b à b et
ab
alors on
- la fonction alors juste avant je fais
une petite pousse pour les questions je
vois que nous avons deux questions qui
sont posées une toute première question
c'est y at il un intérêt particulier à
coder un vecteur logique farce plutôt
comme chaîne de caractère où ils n'ont
alors dans les données des enquêtes en
général sont plutôt côté sous forme ou
oui non et on verra même tout à l'heure
plutôt sous forme de facteurs dans un
certain nombre de cas ça peut être
pratique de coder directement de
chauffage
c'est peu utilisé mais ça peut arriver
et ça peut aussi arriver en fonction du
logiciel qui est utilisé pour collecter
les divines enquête et parfois on va
récupérer donné sous un format qui
étouffe ans on verra plus tard quand on
ferait dur codage de vecteurs on peut
facilement basculer de l'un à l'autre
il faut juste en fait les connaître et
savoir jongler entre les les éléments
alors une deuxième question si air
convertit automatiquement les valeurs en
valeur car l'acteur dans lequel les
types de vecteurs sont différentes
pourquoi y at il besoin d'entourer les
caractères de guillemets alors c'est un
élément globale du langage si je veux
indiquent qu'ils achètent de caractère à
je dois l'entourer de guillemets si je
reviens dans
s'il indique a entre guillemets je
voulais dire c'est le texte ah si je
tape à tout court ça veut dire que je
cherche à charge en mémoire l'objet à
sauf que là j'obtiens message d'erreur
puisque l'objet est introuvable
si je fais l'exemple avec x si je tape x
sans guillemets je désigne l'objet x si
je tape x entre guillemets j'indique la
chaîne de textes x autres quais
peut-on créer un vecteur avec dna et
d'autres classes numériques n a alors
effectivement n a peut s'utiliser avec
n'importe quel type de classe par défaut
elle a un est considéré comme une valeur
logique mais on peut tout à fait mais
dna dans un vecteur numerix je peux
faire un de haine a gelé stocks
dans un objet fed je peux vous affichez
ici l'objet et sigean car la classe deux
aides
je tiens numérique en fait ce qui s'est
passé c'est que comme anna est logique
et que logique peut se transformer vers
tous les autres formats automatiquement
on a une conversion dans certains cas
précis on peut avoir besoin par exemple
quand on créé directement un objet qui
contient que einat mais on veut
spécifier le type on peut utiliser
différentes formes puisque vous avez
aussi n a oublié l amour il en fait
c'est la valeur n à mes forces et en
tant qu'objet numérique
vous avez aussi n à under score
character qui est n à
mais au format character donc à l' usage
on pourra souvent quand on crée des
vecteurs sont contentés de haine à tout
court par contre quand on veut préciser
le type de n a pas ce qu'on en a besoin
à cet endroit là on a en fait à notre
disposition n a character 1a complexe
elle a intégré à ouïr alors n a complex
ce sont pour des nombres complexes nous
les aborderons pas ici à mais ceux
d'entre vous qu on fait des
mathématiques ont peut-être déjà abordé
ce qu'on appelle les nombres complexes
alors je vous propose
revenir à nos créations de vecteurs on
avait déjà vu la fonction reps si je lui
passe une valeur et un nombre de fois où
il faut répéter on va pouvoir répéter
cette valeur mais souvent ceux dont on
aura besoin c'est de pouvoir faire une
chaîne de valeur qui vont s'enchaîner
par exemple 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 pour ça
on pourra avoir recours à une autre
fonction qu'il s'agit de la fonction sec
je vais donner un nom de départ par
exemple 4 un nombre d'arrivées il va me
faire la séquence de nombre avec un pas
de seins de l'un à l'autre donc la sec
de 4,7
ça me fait donc 4 5 6 7 de la même
manière je pourrais faire 13,8 et
j'obtiendrai 13 12 11 10 9 8 sec a
également un troisième argument qui est
l'argument bike permet de dire le pack
en veut utiliser et donc je pourrais
faire sec de 0 à 20 mais avec un pas de
4 et l'âge
0 4 8 12 16 20 et on peut
à négative par exemple sec de sang à 10
avec un pas de -10 de l'avion
dernière à nombres négatifs s'écrit tout
simplement avec le symbole - devant le
nombre et l'âge obtient la séquence sans
90 80 70 60 50 40 35 et 10 l'art en fête
le fait de faire une suite de nombres
ils se suffisent et en fait on le verra
en programmation assez fréquentes
il y à un raccourci pour la fonction
seck qui est le symbole de points si je
tape 12.5 j'obtiens un deux trois quatre
cinq et 11 points 5
c'est équivalent à sec 1,5 part pas de
rien on est toujours avec le symbole de
poing sur un pas deux jeux pourrait par
exemple faire 82.4 et il y aller de
manière décroissante et on peut aussi
s'amuser à faire deux points 5,2 points
7.8 et on aura deux seins 3,5 4,5 5,5 6
5 et 70
alors petit
on qui nous est posée est ce que saic x6
est donc un vecteur oui tout à fait
l'objet renvoyé par saic est un vecteur
donc si jamais je reprends ici l'objet
qui est produit juste ok on va l'appeler
x x est un vecteur 7 vecteur 1 2 3 4 5
si je regarde la classe du x j'obtiens
numérique
donc je sais que x et numérique et pour
vraiment vérifier s'il ya une fonction
qui s'appelle is atomique mais il
atomique ça permet de vérifier si un
objet est un vecteur à et donc si je
fais ici pour atomic 2x j'obtiens de
chou ça me dit que x est un vecteur je
vous montre un exemple si je suis passé
par exemple objets mine qui était une
fonction on a vu la semaine dernière
j'obtiens pharos et ça me dit que mines
n'est pas un vecteur et plus précisément
mines et nous avions vu la semaine
dernière
c'est une fonction alors la
caractéristique essentielle d'un mec
1 c'est sa longueur et la longueur d'un
vecteur s'obtient tout simplement avec
la fonction lines si je fais lines 2x
j'obtiens sahin qui si je regarde x il
contient bien cinq valeurs je pourrais
faire lentz de taille
on a créé tout à l'heure et j'obtiens
4 alors on peut aussi faire un vecteur
de longueur nul si j'appelle c'est sans
fil lui m j'obtiens un objet cet objet
s'appelle nou lé écrit n ul elle en
majuscules et nous lé c'est le vecteur
vide
il ne contient rien si je regarde la
longueur de cet objet nous le job tient
tout simplement zéro alors on l'a vu
c'est nous permet de créer un vecteur
mais ça permet aussi de combiner des
vecteurs entre d'ailleurs c est le
raccourci du mot anglais combined
supposons que j'ai un premier vecteur
donc je verrai
x qui va contenir 1 8 m de longueur 3 je
vais que c'est un deuxième vecteur y qui
va contenir 4 3 7 et 2 et n 1 et donc de
longueur 5
je peux créer un troisième vecteur on
combinant x y
si je fais c'est x virgules y
il va me mettre x et y boutabout et
j'obtiens le vecteur z qui contient les
valeurs 1 8 7 4 3 7 2 et n 1 si je
regarde la longueur de z la longueur de
z est tout simplement de 8,3 +5
alors nous
vu les valeurs manquantes la semaine
dernière a donc deux pays
et quelle est la vraie différence entre
une fonction est un vecteur alors aussi
une différence vraiment de nature une
fonction est un objet d'un type
particulier qui va prendre des arguments
en entrée et qui va envoyer quelque
chose un vecteur est une série de
valeurs
les deux ont un nom les deux sont
appelable de la même manière dans aer
simplement c'est vraiment deux types
d'objets très différents la création
d'un vecteur du même nom qu'un précédent
écrase donc automatiquement ce dernier
tout à fait et c'est même quelque chose
de plus générale levêque l'assignation
c'est à dire la flèche vers la gauche
que l'on a vu et qui permettent de
stocker un résultat dans un objet si je
signe un résultat dans un objet déjà
existants je vais écrasé l'objet
existants et c'est comme ça qu'on va
pouvoir mettre à jour les objets la
question c'est
ton récupérer des vecteurs qui sont
écrasés par erreur est la réponse est
non à partir du moment où un objet a été
effacée en mémoire
on ne peut plus récupérer il est perdu
la mémoire mais c'est pour ça que ça va
être très important on verra sur toi
parti la semaine prochaine quand on va
commencer à faire des analyses
ah non par passer toutes nos commandes
directement dans la console ce que je
fais actuellement pour vous présenter
les bases du langage met à écrire un
script qui va importer des données pu
faire toutes les transformations
l'intérêt c'est que si jamais on a fait
une erreur on va pouvoir les corriger
son script et dorée exécuté depuis le
début et ainsi ne pas perdre les
informations donc c'est vraiment par
rapport à d'autres logiciels il n'y a
pas de touche contre l'aide pour revenir
en arrière on a un un contrôle z dans la
console
quand on écrit du code mais on n'a pas
de contrôle z pour les changements qu'on
a fait sur les objets car qu'on l'écrit
en fait c'est un petit programme donc on
y reviendra un peu plus tard mais sachez
qu effectivement peut pas retrouver un
objet qu'on a changé en mémoire alors
revenons à
nos créations de vecteurs j'ai un petit
peu nettoyer l'écran
donc on l'a vu un on peut utiliser l art
pour un type qui des valeurs manquantes
si je fais et je l'écrasé x1
donc si je fais un vecteur qui contient
nana10 parlant c'est un vecteur qui va
contenir trois valeurs chacune de ces
valeurs et en rend compte
helens 2x vous trois ce qui est très
différent du vecteur vide
supposons que je crée maintenant où je
remplace y par le vecteur vide
combiné avec le vecteur vide et de
vecteurs vide
à votre avis quelle va être la longueur
de ce nouvel objet est bien la longueur
de y
ici est tout simplement zéro et y est
égal aux vecteurs vide et donc c'est
bien pour ça qu'il faut bien comprendre
la différence entre vecteur vide et une
valeurs manquantes une valeur manquante
est une valeur qui existe en tant que
tel qui est contée dans la longueur du
vecteur simplement elle n'est pas
disponible
alors que le vecteur vite c'est un
vecteur qui ne contient rien
alors matin
ont vu à les éléments de base un vecteur
nous allons aborder la notion
d'indexation et nous allons voir la
dégustation ça permet d'accéder à
certaines valeurs d'un vecteur il en
existe trois types indexation par
position par nom est parti alors je
verrai
mon écran et je vais refaire avec leur
taille il va contenir plusieurs valeurs
qui donc l'agent avec turtle
tiens donc
un de ses
et donc ce vecteur paille contient cinq
valeurs qui sont 1 78 1 88 m à 1 99 1 67
si je souhaite acide accéder au deuxième
élément du vecteur times que j'aimerais
récupérer c'est le 1 88
je peux indiquer taille entre crochets
vu passer une position ici je veux le
deuxième élément je fais taille de 2 et
j'obtiens le deuxième élément de mon
lecteur tag jeu pour
vouloir récupérer les trois premiers
éléments pour cela je vais y passer
plusieurs valeurs du passé du coup un
vecteur de position et donc je voulais
passer c'est entre parenthèses un deux
trois qui sont les positions qui
m'intéresse et taille de ces 2 1 2 3 me
permet de récupérer la première la
deuxième et la troisième valeur
je peux très bien récupéré des éléments
dans un autre ordre je pourrais vouloir
le cinquième élément suivi du deuxième
et je suivis du caire si je fais c inq
de quatre dont je crée un vecteur de
position je passe vecteur de position au
vecteur taille dont les crochets il
obtient à ce moment là
à
et j'obtiens à ce moment là l'extraction
demandé alors compte les besoins de
récupérer uniquement des trois premières
valeurs une manière plus courte de
l'écrire consiste à utiliser la notation
avec aidé au point car si je fais 12.3
on l'a vu 12.3 veut dire 1 2 3 et
j'arrive à avoir directement les trois
premières valeurs alors dans les
questions qui arrive
peut-on être amenés à utiliser un
vecteur vide dans la pratique de
l'analyse de nice alors le vecteur vide
nul
il va arriver dans l'analyse de n'est
pas dans le stockage de nos variable
mais il va arriver en tant que
paramètres d'internement fonction par
exemple on va avoir des fonctions qui
vont avoir besoin qui on va passer des
options et dans certains cas on voudra
dire rien et c'est là où on va avoir
besoin du nul
on me demandait ce que nul est égal à
zéro
non zéro est une valeur numérique qui
veut dire zéro nul et ne veut dire rien
c'est un vecteur vide qui ne contient
aucune valeur alors que le vecteur 0 lui
à longueur de 1
pourquoi
qui est une donnée manquante dans un
vecteur quand on sait bien qu'on n'a pas
de valeur pour cette donnée est bien
parce qu'il faut bien qu'on sache qu'il
n'y a pas de valeur pour cet individu là
si j'ai un deuxième vecteur qui contient
le sexe des participants eh bien je
pourrais avoir un vecteur avec cinq
personnes et ici j'ai cinq valeurs pour
ça que c'est une valeur pour taille ce
qui me permet de savoir que on a enquêté
cinq personnes et que pour un des
individus il me manque une valeur donc
manquantes
en fait on verra tout à l'heure lorsque
on va aborder les tableaux de données
mais quand on va aborder des tableaux de
données on a besoin d'autres temps
d'observation qu'il n'ya individus pour
toutes les variables et dont contiennent
pas documenté il faut indiquer à quelque
chose et c'est pour ça qu'on va avoir
besoin de manière forte et valeurs
manquantes
alors je reviens à mon lecteur taille
on a vu que l'on peut tout simplement
extraire des éléments à partir de leurs
positions en passant ses positions qu'il
faut bien comprendre dans la syntaxe
heures c'est que je pourrais très bien
créer un objet qui s'appelle pose et qui
contiendrait les positions qui
m'intéresse par exemple 4 1 et 2 il dira
ensuite taille entre crochets buzz pour
dire que je peux récupérer la taille aux
positions définies par l'objet posons
c'est tout c'est vraiment sympa grand
pouvoir se combiner les uns avec les
autres
ce qu'il faut aussi retenir c'est que si
je demande un élément qui n'existent pas
par exemple je voudrais le dixième
élément de taille
orthwein avec une longueur de 5 j'avais
obtenir donc à présent une valeurs
manquantes avec un n a alors il ya aussi
une petite subtilité dans le cas de
l'indexation par position on peut
également indiqué des positions
négatives et en fait qu'il faut
comprendre c'est une position négative
veut dire tout sauf cette position donc
taille entre crochets -3 veut dire je
veux tous les éléments de taille sauf le
troisième élément et on peut également
donner plusieurs valeurs négatives je
pourrais dire moins
neuf et -4 pour dire je veux tous les
éléments de taille sauf le premier est
sauf le quatrième alors la sq
boire c'est le cas particulier de
l'indexation par position on peut aussi
à utiliser
l'indexation par non pour utiliser
l'indexation par non il va falloir que
l'on commence à donner des noms aux
différents éléments de notre vecteur
alors si on crée le vecteur avec la
fonction c on peut donner des noms sous
la forme non égal à l'heure par exemple
michel faisait 1 m 88 78 sophis mesure 1
mètre 66 mach 1 m 88
eric n'a pas
enquête et enfin civis mesure 1 m
65 donc là
j'ai fait j'ai donné un nom à chacun des
éléments de mon vecteur tide pour autant
taille je vous affiche ici à l'écran
alors quand il est nommé on nous affiche
est non et les valeurs restent
fondamentalement un objet numérique et
je peux tout à fait calculer une moyenne
alors on va préciser n a point rm pour
hennaoui move égal tout pour calculer
notre moyenne donc la seule
particularité c'est que notre vecteur
maintenant à des non et je peux accéder
à ces noms avec nîmes ce donc si je fais
nîmes de taille ça va me sortir la liste
des noms du vecteur alors pour certains
dans certains cas ça va nous être utile
notamment parce que maintenant que nous
avons un vecteur nommé on va pouvoir
récupérer des informations à partir du
nom supposons je souhaite connaître la
taille de marque
je peux
ty je mets les crochets pour en extraire
une partie et je vais mettre le nom qui
m'intéresse
si je passe du coup au crochet non plus
une valeur numérique qui correspondent à
une position mais une valeur textuel qui
creusent point nous je vois extraire
l'élément qui s'appelle marc et ceci peu
importe si marqué la première deuxième
troisième quatrième cinquième valeur
quand je fais une indexation par non peu
importe
du coup l'ordre des différentes valeurs
je peux comme précédemment donné
plusieurs nous par exemple la possible à
la taille 2 sylvie ce et la taille de
sophie donc dans ce cas là j'appelle mes
crochets je lui passe un vecteur de nom
c'est pour ça que j'ai le c à
l'intérieur des crochets ouais c'est
bien important il ya bien un c ouvrez la
parenthèse les deux prénoms à
l'intérieur du crochet je peux pas
directement mettre les prêts les des
valeurs textuelle et l'âge obtient du
coup un sou vecteur qui ne contient plus
que les valeurs pour sylvie et pour
sophie et voyez que les données nous
sont renvoyés dans l'ordre directeur il
est tout à fait possible quand on a un
vecteur de supprimer les noms du vecteur
là je vais faire un nouveau vecteur que
je vais appeler known in est en fait je
vais lui je vais passer la fonction unl
m.hamon objets taille et la fonction
non je vous montre maintenant ce que
vaut anonyme la faune
même un simplement supprime les noms de
mon objet par contre donc on a vu
l'indexation par position je passe une
valeur
je passe donc une valeur numérique au
crochet et donc l'indexation pas
renoncer seal vector est nommé en
passant une valeur textuel il nous reste
enfin un troisième type d'indexation qui
est l'indexation par conditions
alors lundi
on part conditions consiste à passer
cette phase i aux crochets une série de
valeurs de type logique tout fabs donc
reprenons
vecteur pagne jeunes humour affiche
supposons que je veux le premier et le
troisième je pourrais dire que je vais
passer une série de valeurs phares
coucou fars
charles donc
indique je veux la première valeur je ne
veux pas la seconde je veux la troisième
je ne veux pas la quatrième et je ne
veux pas la cinquième
si je pars à cette série de valeurs
logique je vais donc ici extraire la
première et la troisième
l'inter
c'est en fait de l'indexation logique
c'est qu'on va le voir on va pouvoir
faire des opérations logiques sur
d'autres vecteurs
je vous rappel nous avions un deuxième
vecteur qui s'appelait sexe
alors que les prénoms ne correspondent
pas d'en cas présent mais tant pis à
partir de ce vecteur sexe je pourrais
faire une condition logique alors les
conditions logiques sont deux
plusieurs types mais juste avant on va
déjà répondre aux questions qui arrive
on me demande est-ce que - c1 trois
essais un 3 sont identiques
pas vraiment si je fais 6
-
un véhicule - 3 je crée un vecteur qui
contient les
alors moins une et -3 par contre si je
tape moins c'est un droit j'obtiens
aussi ça ce qui se passe c'est qu'en
fait quand on a écrit cette équation là
on a en fait explique moins 20 x c'est
un trois et on a fait cette opération
ceci étant dit - c13 peut prêter à
confusion il est plutôt préférable
d'utiliser la première la première
écriture alors une
comment se fait-il que dans l'écran d'en
haut à droite au vecteur taille
correspondait taille numérique et non
les noms correspondant alors on fait
6 6 1 au fait qu'on a un vecteur est
donc mon vecteur taille
je vous rappelle il contient les valeurs
1 78 1 66 1 188 ena et 1,65 et donc du
coup ce que mashish cet onglet 2 r
studio avec la liste des objets en
mémoire il m'affiche les valeurs de
taille et les valeurs de tri ce sont les
valeurs numériques
par contre il est indiqué par un hymne
de nîmes que c'est un vecteur numérique
qui est dommage
alors déjà taillé on va le dénommé pour
la suite de l'exercice est donc
des notions cette fois ci deux à deux
tests de comparaison on a plusieurs
opérateurs logique dans air déjà on peut
regarder si deux choses sont égales et
ça se fait avec le symbole égale égale 6
oseront pour vérifier si deux choses
sont identiques donc supposons le fasse
trois digues ou plein si je tape 3 égalé
galles 4 j'obtiens faut et si je tape 3
égale égal 3 j'obtiens juste sont
surprises
je vous rappelle nous avons un vecteur
textuel qui contient les valeurs f ou h
si je tape sex & gas légal f
ça va faire le test pour chacune des
valeurs de mon vecteur sexe est donc ici
j'obtiens fou files pas tout
maintenant supposons un deux autres
vecteurs g prendre le vecteur 1 2 3 et
le vecteur y qui va être celui ci le
vecteur 3 2 d'autres opéras
on peut faire sur les valeurs numériques
mais non pas sur des valeurs textual
c'est de regarder c'est quelque chose
est supérieure à une autre
par exemple je vous remontre xo 1 2 3
est-ce que x est supérieure à 2 et bien
j'obtiens south south flou pourquoi
parce que 1 est plus petit que 2 2 n'est
pas strictement supérieure à 2 et 3 et
bien strictement supérieure à 2 si je
veux faire un supérieur ou égal on va
avoir recours aux symboles supérieur
suivi du symbole et gagnent de la même
manière on peut faire le test
est-ce que x est inférieure à 2 ou
est-ce que x est inférieure ou égale à 2
sur ce qui est sûr c'est est ce que l'on
fait sur des vecteurs si jamais je
compare un vecteur avec une valeur
unique
on va du coup faire la comparaison pour
chacune des valeurs du vecteur qui va te
paraît un chacune des valeurs qui va
être comparé à la valeur unique que l'on
a passé une autre possibilité lorsque
l'on à deux vecteurs de même longueur on
l'avait déjà abordé la semaine dernière
contre on fait du calcul sur des
vecteurs des comparaisons entre vecteurs
il vaut mieux avoir des vecteurs de même
longueur
cette fois ci la comparaison se faire 2
à 2 si je fais est-ce que x est égal à y
j'obtiens starts to find puisque
seulement en deuxième position les deux
valeurs sont identiques
si je fais x supérieur ou égal avec
avec j'obtiens south south flou
puisqu'il n'y a qu'en troisième position
où la valeur de x en troisième position
3 est strictement supérieur à la valeur
de les grecs en troisième position alors
l'avantagent d'avoir du coup ces
opérations ces conditions qu'on arrive à
écrire c'est qu'on va pouvoir les
mélanger avec les crochets pour faire du
coup une indexation sur des conditions
alors revenons à l'exemple de taille
elle contient cinq valeurs
numérique saxe est lui aussi de longueur
si l'on suppose que
à
du coup que l'ordre des valeurs
correspondent bien aux mêmes individus
alors je pourrai obtenir la taille des
personnes de sexe féminin en écrivant
taille entre crochets sex & gas légal f
pour rappel sex & gas légal f1 me
renvoyer tous fast food show et cette
série de valeurs logique appliquée à
taille va permettre du coup d'extraire
les données qui correspondent aux femmes
et avant de finaliser
et sur les vecteurs il nous faut voir un
dernier élément qui est comment est-ce
que l'on va combiner indexation et
assignations
revenons son
leur taille taille sans s supposons
finalement j'obtiens une valeur pour le
quatrième élément qui est de 1 m 74
comment est ce que je peux faire cette
modification on l'a vu taille entre
crochets 4 me donne le quatrième élément
si je combine cette extraction avec
l'assignation c'est à dire le fait de
modifier un objet a indiqué par la
flèche et que j'indique 1,74 dans ce cas
là je ne vais modifier que le quatrième
élément et si je regarde taille et bien
on voit que tu ailles a été modifiée
mais que nous on a modifié une élément
est donc en syntaxe airs classiques on
va pouvoir combiner l'indexation le fait
de l'extraire que certains éléments d'un
vecteur avec l'assignation pour modifier
que les éléments correspondant donc si
je résume
concernant les vecteurs un vecteur est
un objet unidimensionnel contenant une
liste de valeurs qui sont tous du même
type
elles sont toutes entières numérique
textuelle ou logique ou d'une autre
classe d'ailleurs la fonction classe
permet de connaître le type du vecteur
et la fonction lines sa longueur la
fonction c'est sert à créer et à
combiner entre des vecteurs des valeurs
manquantes sont représentés avec m
à un vecteur peut être nommé c'est à
dire qu'un nom textuel est associée à
chaque élément
cela se fait lors de la sa création avec
la fonction names l'indexation consiste
à extraire certains éléments d'un
vecteur pour cela on indique ce que l'on
souhaite extraire entre crochets juste
après le nom du vecteur et le type
d'indexation dépend du type
d'informations transmises
s'il s'agit de nombres entiers c'est
indexation par position les nombre
représente la position dans le vecteur
des éléments que l'on souhaite extraire
un nombre négatif s'interprète comme
tous les éléments sauf celui-là
si on indique des chaînes de caractères
c'est indexation part nous on indique le
nom des éléments que l'on souhaite
extraire et cette forme d'indexation ne
fonctionne que si le vecteur est nommé
enfin si l'on transmet des valeurs
logique le plus souvent sous la forme
d'une condition c'est l'indexation par
conditions pour indiquent les éléments
extraire et phase les éléments exclure
enfin il est possible de modifier que
certains éléments d'un vecteur en y ont
recours à la fois l'indexation et à
l'assignation
alors petite question peut-on
vecteur un peu comme taille et bien ici
en fait c'est un petit peu différent on
va jongler le fait ou puisse écrasé
supposons que je ne veux garder que tous
les éléments sauf le quatrième on l'a vu
si je fais taille - 4 ça me prendra tous
vecteurs sauf le quatrième élément ici
je veux sauvegarder cela eh ben je vais
tout simplement remplacé paille hartheim
-4 en disant cela on prend la valeur de
taille on retire le quatrième et d'amour
et tout cela est rangé dans taille
si je regarde maintenant l'objet de
taille il ne contient plus que 1 78 1 66
1 88 et 1 65 alors et
données sur word le coller sur la
console r exécuter différentes
opérations
alors non il n'est pas possible de
copier coller un tableau depuis word
d'une part ward est absolument pas le
format utilisé pour stocker des données
la question pourrait se poser à partir
d'un tableau excel on va voir on peut
importer un tableau excel et aujourd'hui
on est vraiment centré sur les bases du
langage et par la suite on va voir qu'on
a d'autres maquettes j'entame mon petit
plat hier qu'ils vont nous permettre de
manipuler très facilement les nos
valeurs et on fera nos transformation
directement dans l'est
alors je
d'abord dès maintenant un deuxième type
d'objet d'un erp ce qu'on voit que les
vecteurs sont plutôt limitées et
d'aborder la notion de liste
or on l'a vu un parti
les vecteurs ne peuvent contenir que des
valeurs de même type or dans 1 42 k on
peut avoir besoin de stocker 200 va même
objet des éléments qui sont disparates
c'est ce que permet de faire des listes
ans et une liste secrète ou simplement
avec la fonction liste
alors on va créer une première liste
qui va contenir un 2.5 pour rappel ça
vaut 1 2 3 4 5 et le texte a baissé
je vous affiche maintenant à l'écran ma
liste
alors la chicha
un petit peu différent mais on voit
qu'on a un premier élément qui est le
vecteur numérique 1 2 3 4 5
il ya un deuxième élément qui est le
vecteur abaissé d'une longueur une si je
regarde la classe
de l'objet l1 j'obtiens liste si
j'aurais
car la longueur de ma liste je
1 2 donc la longueur d'une liste c'est
le nombre d'objets qui sont stockés dans
la liste et là en l'occurrence j'ai une
liste qui contient deux vecteurs
de longueur 1 il ya un deuxième vecteur
de longueur 2
je vais maintenant créer une deuxième
liste je vais appeler l2 et qui va
contenir cette fois ci un vecteur qui
est de 5 6 8
mon objet
ty hémon objets sexe si j'affiche à
l'écran
j'ai une liste qui contient trois
éléments la suite de nom 2 5 6 8
un deuxième vecteur qui contient 1 78 66
1 88 et 1 65 et 1 troisième vecteur qui
contient cinq valeurs textuel donc ce
qu'on peut voir si kunis peut contenir
des objets de différentes natures et il
peut contenir des vecteurs qui ont des
longueurs différentes
si je regarde la longueur de l2
la longueur de l2 c'est tout simplement
3 pour rappel la longueur c'est le
nombre d'éléments stockés dans mon dans
ma liste je peux aussi nommer les
éléments d'une liste supposons que je
reprends la liste l2 mais l'ordre
non je vais appeler le premier élément x
le deuxième je l'appelais taille et le 3
les sexes comme tout à l'heure pour
nommer les éléments d'une liste quand on
crée not least on va avoir recours à
l'écriture sous la forme non égale
valeur c'est-à-dire non de l'argument
égale valeur de l'argument ici je vous
montre maintenant l'objet l2 la seule
différence par rapport à tout à l'heure
c'est que maintenant c'est devenu un
objet nous mais et je peux accepter au
nom des objets avec nemce question un
peu
subtil que se passe-t-il si je fais la
commande
elle est égale à liste de l1 et l2 pour
rappel liste
l un est une liste d'objets l2 est une
liste de trois objets je crée maintenant
une nouvelle liste elle qui contient l1
et l2
la question c'est quelle est la longueur
de mon objet elle est la longueur de
monde d'objets l es deux longueurs d'eux
si on regarde en fait l'objet elle alors
c'est pas forcément bien visibles comme
ça on va utiliser du coup la fonction
ftr pour mieux voir la structure de
l'objet elle en fait elle contient deux
objets qui sont de liste on est donc une
liste peu à elle-même contenir des
listes si on regarde enseigne histoire
de boîtes dans les boîtes ou de
répertoires dans des répertoires
on a donc elle une liste qui contient
deux autres listes une première liste
qui contient des vecteurs et une
deuxième liste qui contient trois
vecteurs
si ce qu'on aurait voulu faire c'était
en fait à vouloir une liste qui contient
les cinq objets c'est à dire qu'on
aurait voulu mettre les éléments de
l'est de l2 à la suite des éléments de
l1 ça ne se fait pas avec elle mais ça
se fait que la fonction à peine
donc si j'avais plutôt fait la commande
suivante elle égale ap end de l1 l2 ce
genre
j'ai que j'ai obtenu là j'aurai une
liste de cinq qui aurait mis les objets
de l1 de l2 à la suite des objets de l
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est qu'une
liste peut contenir n'importe quel autre
type d'objets y compris des listes comme
pour les vecteurs il est possible
d'extraire des objets de ma liste et on
a encore une fois recours au crochet si
je fais l 4 j'obtiens le quatrième
objets contenus dans la liste si je fais
l crochet 42.5 j'obtiens le quatrième et
le cinquième
objets contenus dans la liste de la même
année
peut avoir recours à l'indexation par
non si je fais elle et que je lui passe
x j'obtiens l'objet x où je peux lui
passé plusieurs valeurs et je vais dire
ce que je veux x et sexe et j'obtiens
les deux objets voulu et on peut tout à
fait utiliser également l'indexation
par contre
on en est
les éléments que l'on souhaite extraire
avec 7
là j'ai bien extrait le premier le
troisième et le cinquième élément de ma
liste elle alors
il ya malgré tout une petite subtilité
c'est que si j'extrais le premier
élément en faisant elle crochet un ce
que je vais obtenir
on va le voir avec stm c'est également
une liste quand on utilise les crochets
sur une liste on va récupérer une
soulist avec les éléments demandés si on
voulait calculer la moyenne sur ce
vecteur là j'obtiens un problème parce
que je ne peux pas calculer les moyennes
sur une liste
et donc
mon problème ici c'est que l crochet 1
ne m'a pas renvoyé le vecteur 1 2 3 4 5
et ça m'a envoyé une liste qui contient
le vecteur 1 2 3 4 5 et donc si l'on
souhaite plutôt récupérer l'objet
stockées en première position pas une
liste qui ne contiendrait que le premier
objet mais l'objet d'une première
position on va avoir besoin des double
crochet alors pour ceux qui font déjà du
r depuis quelques temps vous avez
peut-être vu les double crochet sans
vraiment connaître la différence
les double crochet permettent de dire
dans une liste je veux extraire le
premier élément et c'est cet élément là
que je veux qu'ils me soient renvoyés si
je regarde la structure de sr de l
double crochet 1
j'ai un vecteur avec les valeurs 1 2 3 4
5 et je peux calculer dessus moi moyenne
et donc du coup il ya une vraie
différence entre les crochets simple et
les crochets double les crochets simple
permet de renvoyer une liste avec un
nombre plus réduit d'éléments et donc l
crochet 1 me renvoie une liste contenant
le premier élément de ma vie ce qui est
donc le vecteur à 2.45 tandis que els
double crochet 1 me permets de renvoyer
le contenu de cet élément là par contre
je ne dois pas lui passer plusieurs
valeurs numériques 1 l'a congédie double
crochet c'est pour extraire un seul et
unique élément je peux aussi utiliser du
coup la syntaxe est double crochet à
partir d'un nom je pourrais écrire elle
entre crochets taille ce qui me permet
d'extraire l'objet nommé taille
or c'est
sur la elle double crochet entre
guillemets taille peut écrire aussi plus
rapidement sous la forme elle dollars
taille
elle dollars taille veut dire je veux
l'objet taille contenu dans l
et c'est tout à fait équivalent à
l'écriture elle double crochet entre
guillemets taille c'est beau
j'affiche la structure de ma liste l
hymne affiche $ x dollars taille de leur
sexe pour me rappeler cette syntaxe qui
est propre
ar alors quelques questions est ce qui
est différent
un vecteur helens d'une liste
fondamentalement non mais
ça ne rentre pas tout à fait la même
chose la longueur d'un vecteur c'est le
nombre de valeurs contenues dans le
vecteur la longueur d'une liste c'est le
nombre d'objets stockés dans la liste
quelle que soit la longueur des objets
qui sont stockés
un jeu de données peut-il être stockée
sous forme de liste tout à fait un jeu
de données peut être stockée sous forme
de liste mais on va voir d'ici quelques
minutes que pour un jeu de données
on va avoir recours un style de un type
de liste un petit peu particulier qu'on
appelle les tableaux de données et
tableau donnait en fait sont des listes
or on l'a vu les listes sont un objet
souple dont air et les listes peuvent
stocker n'importe quel type d'autres
objets la longue
d'une liste c'est donc nombre d'objets
qui sont stockés dans la liste les
objets peuvent être nommés on peut
utiliser l'indexation avec les crochets
simple les crochets double permettent au
lieu d'avoir un sou éléments une lutte
avec moins d'éléments d'extraire un
élément particulier donc il ya une vraie
différence entre le crochet simple et le
crochet double et le crochet double
quand il utilisait avec un nom d'objets
peut être remplacé par le symbole
dollars et on me demande pourquoi le
symbole dollars et non symbole euros
tout simplement parce que le symbole de
l'art d'un symbole qui existent en
informatique depuis les commencements
l'informatique etc c'est un symbole qui
est facilement accessible sur les
claviers et qu'il faut pas oublier que
ère a commencé à être codée dans les
années 80-90 donc avant l'existence même
de l'euro
alors on va le bout
pour nos données on va avoir souvent
recours un tableau de données ou data
frame en anglais et les datas forem ou
tableaux de données vont être en fait un
type de lys particulier dont air du coup
ses tableaux de données sont tout
simplement des listes qui ont quelques
propriétés spécifiques souvent nous
donner quand on les voit on peut les
voir sous excel ou dans d'autres
logiciels c'est sous la forme d'un grand
tableau avec nos variable en colonne et
nos observations en ligne une
particularité du tableau de données
c'est qu'un tableau données ne peut
contenir que des vecteurs
il n'y a pas d'histoire de tableau dans
un tableau dans un tableau comme avec
les listes tous les vecteurs d'un
tableau de données ont la même longueur
en fait dans un tableau donné on va
imposer qu'on a le même nombre
d'observations pour toutes nos variable
et c'est pour ça qu'on va avoir besoin
de la valeur elle n'a compté
observations sur mon compte et enfin
dans un tableau de données on a vu pour
les listes il était possible que des
éléments de la liste n'est pas de nous
dans un tableau de données il est
obligatoire que toutes les colonnes est
un nom dont tous les éléments mon
tableau données sont des vecteurs de
même longueur
ils ont tous un nom et ce nom va être
unique
autrement dit toutes nos variables vont
être nommés alors je vais déjà vous
montrer un petit exemple d'un tableau de
données et on va le faire à la main on
va avoir par la suite près jamais de
donner à la main on va toujours les les
importer mais faisons un tout premier
tableau de données avec et on peut
tableaux de données avec la fonction
data from au pardon
donc d'après mme entre pas
thèse non ma première variable égal donc
là on
quatre individus une femme et deux
hommes pas
1 j'ai fait une erreur
saisie deuxième élément à charge
on va considérer de sondés
1 et 3
bhl je faire
logique parce qu'on peut le faire c'est
pour l'exemple qu'ils vont dire ces
personnes sont blondes ou non toujours
face donc là
et un tout premier tableau de donner des
f ici vous voyez en haut à droite dans
l'environnement d'hathaway l'objet des
airs qui a quatre observations et trois
variables
si je la fiche dans ma console vous le
voyez ici mais trois trois variables
mais trois colonnes sexe âge et blond et
nos quatre observations fondamentalement
dfc tunis avec trois vecteurs le vecteur
sexe qu'un vecteur de type character le
vecteur âge qui est un vecteur de type
numérique est le vecteur blond qui est
un vecteur de type logique si je fais
str d'edf je retrouve ces
informations-là quatre observations de
trois variables
vous retrouvez le symbole âge avec nos
trois variables et le type de ces
variables c'est chapeau character même
pour numérique logique pour logique une
note
hier devoir me donnez nous l'avions
rapidement aperçue la semaine dernière
c'est de regarder l'explorateur dans les
studios vous voyez à côté d'edf et une
petite icône en forme de tableur si je
clique dessus ça me permet de voir mon
tableau de donner leur latin tableaux de
données très simple puisque nous avons
que trois variables et quatre colonnes
qu'il faut retenir c'est que
fondamentalement même si la classe d'edf
ces dates a frame les datas fremm leçon
qu un type
wald
l'autre donnée de lise pardon alors on
me demande est ce qu arrivera-t-il si on
travaille qu'un tableau de données ayant
des vecteurs de longueurs différentes
c'est juste pas possible un tableau de
données a obligatoirement des vecteurs
de même longueur il n'est donc pas
possible d'avoir un tableau de données
avec un vecteur de longueurs différentes
et à l' usage
si vous travaillez avec spss ou avec sa
taille ou avec sas dans un fichier de
données vous avez toujours le même
nombre d'observations pour tout le monde
ce qui peut arriver c'est que vous ayez
des observations manquantes
et c'est bien là où vous savez très
important d'avoir du coup cette valeur n
a par contre dans un même tableau toutes
les variables ont le même nombre
d'observations par construction alors si
je
mais la nhtsa
d'edf je lui demande à calculer la
longueur de mon tableau comme mon
tableau en fait est une liste et dans
une liste et le nombre d'objets qu'il
contient et qui sait des objets sont les
différentes variables
je tiendrai donc 3 mais on le voit un
tableau de données comme tous les
vecteurs en la même longueur on peut le
voir comme un objet à deux dimensions
avec un nombre de colonnes et un nombre
de lignes et c'est pour ça que soit
tableaux de données
on aura plutôt l'habitude d'utiliser la
fonction ngolle qui veut dire nombre de
colonnes ou nrao qui veut dire le nombre
de lignes au revoir au signifiant ligne
en anglais
à la longue
leur entente
l'insee 3 c'est le nombre de variables
puisque c'est fondamentalement une liste
mon auraient plutôt recours à ngolle
ngolle si je fais nîmes ce d'edf
j'obtiendrai aussi le nom de mes
différentes variables
techniquement
on peut aussi donner des noms à nos
observations avec la fonction web point
names je vais pas l'aborder plus avant
parce que au quotidien on l'utilisent
quasiment jamais alors je vous
f sous les yeux qu'en est-il de
l'indexation avec les crochets si je
fais tf entre crochets 1
j'obtiens
ablo il contient que ma première
variable
c'est comme une lice dans une liste
quand on dise le crochet simple on
obtient du coup une soulist avec les
éléments de demander est ce qui compose
la bo données sont des variables aussi
le fait et df entre crochets simple et
que je lui passe une série de noms je
pourrais faire à blond et âge et
j'obtiens du coup
à un sou tableau avec uniquement les
vagues demandé supposons que je veux
calculer un âge moyen
si je fais mine d'edf entre crochets âge
je vais avoir un problème parce qu edf
âge entre crochets m'envoie un sou
tableau avec une seule variable pour
accéder à la variable elle-même je dois
passer par les double crochet
on ne sait jamais au quotidien parce que
dans ces cas-là on utilise toujours la
notation des f dollars aïe mais quand je
veux obtenir en fait la variable âge du
tableau des f
et bien c'est de là que vient cet axe
avec avec le dollar pour accéder
directement à une variable du tableau
particularité d'un tableau de données
à vue dans un tableau de donner toutes
les variables ont la même longueur
puisqu'on a le même nombre
d'observations pour toutes les variables
et donc on peut voir un tableau donnait
comme un espace à deux dimensions et ces
deux là qu'arrive la notation avec les
crochets à deux dimensions en rajoutons
une virgule à l'intérieur des crochets
compte entre mes crochets je rajoute une
virgule
j'indique air que je veux notation à
deux dimensions la première dimension ce
sera les lignes la deuxième les colonnes
si jamais 2 3
ça veut dire que je veux la deuxième
valeur de la troisième colonne en
l'occurrence le trou qui est ici alors
que si je fais des f 3,2 j'indique que
je veux la troisième ligne de la
deuxième colonne et j'obtiens donc ce 27
je peux également m rien à gauche ou à
droite de la virgule si je fais des f
proches
et 4,2 veut dire que je veux la
quatrième ligne
mais toutes les variables cij indique dr
gül une je veux dire que je veux la
première colonne et toutes les
observations comme tout à l'heure
lorsque j'indique des positions je peux
y mettre des valeurs négatives si je
fais des f - 2 ça veut dire toutes les
lignes sauf la deuxième
on peut combiner les différentes formes
d'indexation je peux du coup dire que je
veux toutes les lignes sauf la deuxième
est que je veux la variable blond donc
là j'ai passé
une valeur tech
imposition donc l'indexation par non et
j'ai passé avant la virgule ma sélection
sur les lignes je peux également
utiliser ça pour extraire certaines
données supposons que je veux que les
données pour les femmes
c'est donc celle où la variable sexe
vaut deux pour accéder à la variable
sexe du tableau ds cdf dollars sexe égal
f
et là j'ai directement extraites toutes
les observe
des femmes
qui
toujours évident en fait c'est qu'on
peut complètement mélanger ces
différents types de notation si je
voulais l'âge des femmes d'accord
j'aurais pu écrire pour avoir je lâche
des femmes je peux écrire avec le
crochet simple df dollars sex & gas
légal f virgule et j'indique que je veux
la colonne âge
ouf je peux sérieuse
sectionne toutes les observations des
femmes ça me renvoie un tableau sur
lequel je peux réappliquer micros chez
double ou sur lequel je pourrais mettre
le dollar âge où je pourrais faire
encore quelque chose d'un peu différent
je fais dfh qui me renvoie le vecteur h
et là avec des crochets simple sans
virgule puisque je suis maintenant dans
un vecteur met ma condition df sex & gas
légal f
donc là tout ce que vous voyez on voit
la même chose c'est juste des manières
différentes de combiner les crochets et
le dollar ce qu'il faut retenir c'est
que lorsqu'on applique le crochet sur un
tableau de données il faut penser à
mettre la virgule pour pouvoir indiquer
une section sur les lignes puis sur les
colonnes si on ne met pas la virgule
dans les crochets quand il s'applique un
tableau à son volant dans une section
dit mot sur les variables puisque l'on
passe au mode de fonctionnement de type
liste où on peut aussi effectivement
déjà extraire une variable comme je fais
ici avec des f âge et à ce moment là les
crochets s'applique sur le vecteur âge
d'edf
à
et dans ce cas là les crochets ici se
font sans virgule puisque je fais une
section sur les éléments du vecteur âge
et donc sur les lignes donc c'est vrai
que la syntaxe classique de r elle peut
perturber au début sur cette combinaison
entre les crochets et les dollars on
verra un peu plus tard
tam en fait à partir de janvier la
semaine prochaine on va être plutôt sûr
abordé la statistiques descriptives de
base on va commencer vraiment aborder la
manipulation plus avant cette donnée à
partir de janvier
le canton va passer avec le package type
là hier et aux tailles diverses on va
pouvoir se passer de cette syntaxe de
dollars est crochet par quelque chose
qui est plus efficace
cependant vous serez très souvent
confrontés aux crochets et au dollar et
donc c'est important de bien
compromettre différence entre les deux
entre les deux alors
deux questions à quel moment peut-on
extraire une variable 100 dollars comme
on le voit souvent dans des scripts
alors extrêmement variables 5 dollars
s'est passé par les double crochet ou
alors par la syntaxe avec la virgule
si je fais des véhicules âge l'âge
extrêmement variables âge dans les
crochets simple mais avec la vieille pub
pour faire ma section sur les lignes on
verra comme lady en janvier comment est
ce qu'on va pouvoir gérer sa manière un
petit peu plus propre un peu plus
intuitive quand on passera aux tailles
diverses
mais pour ça il faut déjà qu'on est un
peu plus avancés sur les bases du logo
peut-on trouver des exercices sur le net
pour mettre en application ce cours
alors effectivement si vous allez sur le
site analyseur ce que l'on voit
aujourd'hui un fait partie du cours
liste et tableaux de données
vous allez retrouver
avec
surtout ce que tout ce que je suis en
train de vous dire par contre il n'ya
pas d'exercice ici alors normalement
pas dans le cours d'introduction
d'interdît verse du vin barnier qui est
disponible
sur juba point dit à ben points et au
slash tailles diverses
je crois que l'exercice on va si je vais
sur le chapitre premier travail avec une
année vous avez tout en bas dans ce
chapitre là une série d'exercices qui
vous est présentée ici est donc on va
vous pourrez trouver des exercices pour
vous aider avec les solutions qui sont
données donc peut-être plus tôt dans le
premier chapitre qui va être prise en
main puis dans le chapitre premier trail
avec les données alors là on commence à
voir qu'en combinant tous ces éléments
là on va pouvoir manipuler plus finement
les objets qu'ils ont créés sous there
c'est pas le but d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment on voit
vraiment les éléments de syntaxe de base
mais à partir la semaine prochaine on va
voir comment on va pouvoir mettre tout
ça ensemble
aujourd'hui j'aimerais encore abordé
quelques éléments un peu fondamentaux et
nous allons enchaîner sur la notion de
facteurs parce qu'on va en avoir besoin
dès la semaine prochaine
alors on l'a vu dans les types
principaux
de deux vecteurs nous avons les vecteurs
textuel les vecteurs numérique et les
lecteurs
entier et les vecteurs logique les
vecteurs textuel peuvent stocker
absolument tout type d'information mais
son travail avec des données qui
viennent en quête n'osant que les
vecteurs sexuelle correspondrait plutôt
à des questions ouvertes sein ou l'anc
et hors horaires taper directement ce
qui aurait été dit par l'enquêté sauf
que dans la majorité des cas de figure
ce que l'on a dans nos enquêtes ce sont
des variables catégorielles où le nombre
de possibilités sont limitées
typiquement une question sexe avec
seulement deux options qui sont hommes
et femmes
alors on va prendre un exemple qui vais
charger le paquet
chez nerfs que nous avions vu la semaine
dernière et je vais charger en mémoire
un objet donc data hdv 2003 c'est pour
charger le fichier à gvt et 2003
d'exemples qui est fournie par
questionnaire vous voyez que maintenant
il est maintenant en mémoire ici
d'accord
si je regarde c'est un tableau de
données qui contient 2000 observation
pour 20 variables différentes qui sont
affichées si je fais ftr pour voir la
structure de cet objet
vous verrez que pour
deux variables comme ici la variable
sexe elle n'est pas cotée sous forme
textuelle mais l'écho des sous forme de
facteurs une autre manière de regarder à
notre fichier je voulais présenter
rapidement la semaine dernière c'est la
fonction look for cij a pris la fonction
look fort sur l'objet hdv 2003 elle ma
fille
des variables et je vois ici que la
variable sexe et le type f c'était donc
c'était pour factor avec deux modalités
possibles qui sont hommes et femmes j'en
profite pour vous montrer ici qu'avec la
fonction look fort on voit que l'âge est
codé ici sous forme intel integer donc
c'est un nombre entier entre 1897 et
vous verrez aussi un peu plus bas qui a
une variable qui s'appelle heures point
tv qui le nombre d'heures moyenne passée
- télévision et qui l écho d andy beal
alors dit bl ne soyez pas de ces pots
jabber et jabba ça veut dire variable
numérique je vous l'avais dit au tout
début la session d'aujourd'hui a d'abord
puis est aussi un synonyme pour les
variables numérique
alors revenons à hama
abl sexe si j'aurais
la classe de cet objet donc hdv 2003
dollars sexe
en fait c'est un facteur alors là un
facteur en fait c'est une variable n'ya
que certaines réponses possibles et pour
connaître les réponses possibles d'un
facteur on va avoir recours à la
fonction la barousse si je fais les
verts de hdv 2003 sexe ou pardon 2003
on voit
peut on se possibles qui sont hommes et
femmes et qu'il faut retenir c'est que
ça a un impact quand on valoir fer dure
codage supposons par exemple que pour
l'individu numéro 3 en fait cet individu
ne se reconnaît ni comme omnicom femme
et aurait une identité de genre non
binaire si je veut modifier qu'une
certaine valeur on peut tout à fait
faire à genève et 2003 sexe troisième
position et changer sa valeur mais si
jamais non binaire
ici voyez jeu
j'ai un warning c'est plus une erreur ça
s'est exécuté mais j'ai un warning qui
me dit il valait tracteur laval un match
de retard
cela me dit niveau de facteurs invalides
et ça du coup créer une valeur montante
si je regarde maintenant qu'est-ce que
ce contient hdv 2003 dollars sexe en
troisième position
eh bien j'ai obtenu une valeurs
manquantes parce que je n'avais pas le
droit
alors que
j'avais mis femme qui une des valeurs
autorisées à ce moment là
pour ai pas eu de problème et là je peux
tout à fait maître cette valeur là alors
ce qu'il faut retenir avec les facteurs
c'est que les factor il nous impose sa
montre de valeur autorisée à l'import ça
va pas trop poser de problème on
abordera début janvier sur la session
consacrée au recomptage de variables
comment est-ce qu'on peut transformer
nos facteurs comme votre qu'on peut
changer les valeurs qui sont autorisés
mais il faut retenir voilà qu'on peut
avoir une petite subtilisés
ap
et si vraiment
voir rapidement comment est-ce qu'on
peut changer les modalités d'un facteur
c'est de transformer le facteur vent
variable
art acteur puis le reconvertir en
facteur ça peut se faire avec quelques
fonctions simples par exemple à ce
caractère hommes permet de transformer
une variable
en version texte soit lent
si je fais cette opération là je vais
prendre hd vie 2003 sexe le transformer
en variable textuelle et je re stock mon
résultat dans ma variable sexe ce qui
fait que j'ai changé ma variable sexe si
je regarde la classe 2 hdv 2010
un dollar sexe elle est
l'ips textuel maintenant je peux faire
du coup ce type de transformation
puisque
mettre n'importe quelle valeur textuelle
et je peux éventuellement reconvertir ma
variable sexe en un facteur avec hdv
2003 dollars saks qui va être remplacé
par un facteur des facteurs secret avec
la fonction factor de hdv 2003 dollars
sexe si je regarde
maintenant ma variable ça qu'on va faire
on va passer par le confort donc look
fort de hdv 2003 et je vais indiquer est
ce pour filtrer invariable sexe est
maintenant un facteur avec trois valeurs
possibles qui sont femmes hommes et non
binaire on verra par la suite qu'on peut
faire de nombreuses manipulations sur
les facteurs avec notamment le parquet
de pau caps qui fait partie du tailles
diverses
on verra que questionnaire nous fournit
deux petits a dit mme qui vont être des
types d'interfaces graphiques pour
facilement faire des transformations et
des transformations sur nos facteurs et
la question pour que vous allez
logiquement vous poser est pourquoi ne
pas avoir directement des variables de
type textuel si on n'a pas des variables
de type textuel mais plutôt des
variables de type facteur c'est parce
que ça va permettre de contrôler l'ordre
des différentes modalités et on en aura
besoin
par exemple pour faire des modèles
logistique on va avoir besoin d'indiquer
quels sont les barrettes de référence ou
lorsqu on va faire des graphiques ou des
tableaux et que l'on veut afficher les
éléments dans un ordre donné par exemple
si je voulais affiché hommes femmes non
binaire plutôt que femme homme et non
binner et donc c'est pour ça que avec un
facteur va pouvoir changer l'ordre des
modalités et ça a permis d'avoir un
contrôle beaucoup plus important encore
une fois je sais que c'est frustrant
parce que vous auriez envie qu'on puisse
aborder tout ça dès maintenant
malheureusement il va falloir qu'on
puisse voir encore d'autres éléments
avant cela et donc du coup on abordera
en détail our abordera en détail les
transformations et de reconnaître deux
variables dans une session dédiée au
début du mois de janvier alors une des
sion qui ai demandé qu'est ce que peut
faire des variables caractère versus des
variables type facteurs c'est ce que je
vous disais un instant on va le voir
qu'on va faire de la statistiques
descriptives la statistique multivariée
les données catégories elles doivent
être codé sous forme de facteurs est en
fait dans les différentes fonctions
quand on passe des variables textuel
elles sont à la volée transformer en
variable facteurs et dans un certain
nombre de cas on va avoir besoin
d'indiquer précisément dans quel ordre
doivent être considérées les différentes
valeurs du facteur ce qui ne peut pas
être stockée dans une variable de type
textuel
alors malgré tout 1
c'est la vie dans un premier temps je
vous présente très rapidement les deux
petits à dean qui sont fournies par
cautionneur alors le principe des add in
c qui ressemble de package peuvent
fournir des petites extensions qui
apparaissent dans leur studio ici voyez
en haut vous avez un menu à dean et
quand vous avez des package installés
ils peuvent du coup rajouter des
éléments là dedans alors moi j'en ai
beaucoup de package qui sont installés
mais on va aller chercher ceux qui sont
fournis par le package questionnaire et
il en propose deux vous avez d'une part
le package l'ibérique odinga alors je
vais cliquer dessus
je vais choisir mon tableau de données
hdv 2003 je vais choisir une variable
que je veux recoder par exemple niveau
études je vais indiqué est ce que je
veux créer une nouvelle variable ou
remplacer si je mets le même nom je vais
remplacer la variable existantes
si je veux créer une nouvelle variable
je vais mettre un autre nom de m études
on a plusieurs thrillers codage on va
voir aujourd'hui uniquement caractère
minimale mais on verra plus tard et
c'était huit côtes quand on aura abordé
le tailles diverses
maintenant emballages étaient sous
l'onglet variable et paramètres de le
passer sous l'onglet reco d'âge et ça va
permet de pouvoir là vous allez les
valeurs existantes et je vais pouvoir
renommée par exemple j'ai remplacé n'a
jamais fait d'études par primaire pareil
arrêté ses études et dernière année
d'études puis je vais créer une
catégorie secondaire avec premier cycle
puis je vais avoir ici un troisième
appelée technique qui va regrouper en
fait les enseignement technique et
professionnel
et enfin dernière catégorie supérieure
donc en fait sous l'onglet baril
m indique qu'elle est l'objet est la
variable que je veux transformer ensuite
bien dit qu'elle est la nouvelle vague
que je veux obtenir
je veux obtenir une variable de type
facteurs jeunes bien ici dans reco
d'alger les anciennes valeurs et j'en
dis qu'à droite les nouvelles valeurs
que je veux avoir
et enfin je clique sur que des résultats
qu'est ce que fait le raid in de nadine
me crée le code correspondant
si vous regardez qu'est ce qu'ils me
proposent comme code il prend la
variable nive étude la transforme avec
un tracteur en variable textuelle et
stocks le résultat dans une variable
études puis il prend la variable études
il regarde dans le chaos ni d'étude vaud
n'a jamais fait d'études il remplace par
primaire
donc ici on a une série voiliers de
conditions basé sur les anciennes
valeurs et dans ce cas là je fais une
transformation qui nouvelles valeurs et
enfin à la fin je prends ma balle à
l'étude et je transforme en facteurs
la terre
c'est que ça me permet de voir ici et en
plus il me met un tableau pour montrer
les commandes mais dans une valeur et
mes nouvelles valeurs pour vérifier que
mon âge est correct
le fait que l etat pro codage plusieurs
catégories et soit remplacé par une même
catégorie va me permettre de fusionner
des modalités en sont
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que là je
vais copier
qu au delà
mais par défaut ce que fait le made in
il me génère du code
il ne l'exécutent pas d'accord là il me
donne le code généré je vais copier le
code dans la console on verra la semaine
prochaine dans un script de directement
mais ça va être à nous de décider de
l'exécuter j'exécute le code et voyons
voir
avec
look fort donc dans la gv et 2003 à quoi
ressemble ma variable
on voit que j'ai une variable
hudon qui est un facteur avec quatre
valeurs primaire secondaire supérieur et
technique si je voulais faire un petit
tableau de fréquences et là on va voir
la fonction table aura bordera la
semaine prochaine la fonction table qui
permet de faire un tableau de fréquences
si je fais des deux études
pardon hdv 2003 il me présente dans
l'ordre le niveau primaire puis le
niveau secondaire puis le niveau
supérieur puis le niveau technique
la semaine prochaine on verra comment
est ce qu'on va pouvoir faire des
graffitis les tableaux beaucoup plus
avancé avec les tableaux de fréquences
et pourcentage mais si vous réfléchissez
bien ici c'est un petit peu dérangeant
de présenter le groupe technique avant
après le groupe supérieure puisque en un
sens au niveau d'étude peut être vu
comme une variable structuré et donc
technique devrait aller entre
secondaires et supérieures ce que m'a
fait par défaut en fait factor tout à
l'heure c'est de me mettre les variables
dans l'ordre alphabétique
c'est là où il ya un deuxième a dit in
the quest ix honneur qui va être très
utile qui s'appelle li valls ordering je
lance le had in je vais choisir mon
tableau de données hdv 2003 c'est la
colonne études que je veux transformer
je veux garder donc le nom de variable
ici ne va pas changer parce que je veux
simplement remplacé étude parue nous par
une nouvelle version
je vais encore une fois on a deux styles
de reco d'âge
on abordera for cats plus tard au mois
de janvier
mais là on va déjà voir le facteur je
clique serait ordonnée et la part des
glisser déposer la souris je peux
choisir un nouvel ordre pour mais
variable et je vais aller d'encoder
résultat est là je vois la proposition
de code qui est fait est en fait pour
pouvoir préciser un ordre spécifique
à mes différentes valeurs en fait on
appelle factor on dit avec le paramètre
clauzel on va dire l'ordre spécifique
des variables que l'on veut avoir
je clique sur donne ça m'a copié ici un
code que je vais copier contrôle s'est
collé dans la console est exécuté si
maintenant je fais table de hdv
un dollar étude voyez que
dans l'ordre des modalités est différent
c'est celui que j'ai données primaires
secondaires techniques puis supérieur on
peut le voir aussi avec la fonction
loupe fort donc look fort
hdv 2003 kim affiche toutes les
variables de mon document hdv 2003 et
quand je vais sur l'étude et à la fin
oui c'est un facteur et on à l'ordre et
différents éléments du réacteur alors on
voit ici une autre caisse
quel est l'intérêt de transformer une
variable en facteurs
textual et inversement si on revient sur
le code de tout à l'heure le code de
recodification que vous avez ici là en
fait on est passé par un format texte
fait parce que formaté que soient les
plus faciles à manipuler pour faire
notre transformation et on ne remuons
facteurs au début c'est vrai que c'est
pas toujours évident quel est l'intérêt
d'avoir un acteur versus à une balade
textuel mais là par exemple dire que je
veux que techniques soient présentes
avant supérieur je ne peut le faire
qu'avec un facteur dans une vague
textuel je ne peux pas le faire si je
faisais un tableau de donner un tableau
de fréquences j'aurai toujours
uniquement l'ordre alphabétique avec une
variable de type textuelle et c'est pour
ça qu'on va jongler entre les deux et on
verra plus tard pour certains modèles
notamment des beautés de régression
logistique et notamment si on fait des
modèles ordi nous il est important de
préciser l'ordre des différentes
modalités
ils aiment rester 1
mon un peu technique a abordé ce soir
à
je sais que c'est un petit peu dur c'est
la notion d'éthique est de variables
mais ça va nous servir la semaine
prochaine alors ça c'est quelque chose
qui va surtout parler aux utilisateurs
de spss stata ou de sas dont l'espèce
est apte à et saas
il est fréquent de pouvoir donner une
étiquette à des variables c'est à dire
un long et il est également fréquent de
pouvoir utiliser des étiquettes de
valeur c'est-à-dire ont lieu de coder
notre va sexe on va la côte est par
exemple sa forme un femme deux hommes
neufs ne sait pas alors
abordons des jalles et rillettes de
variables pour tout ce qui va être
étiquette de variables et étiquettes de
valeur il y à un package qui permet de
gérer ça c'est l'extension label d' que
je vais charger en mémoire
alors pour les étiquettes de variables
c'est à dire que je vais donner
un boulon à une variable on va le faire
avec la fonction var underscore label
par exemple j'utilise
elle pour la variable
âge et je vais lui attribuer une itt
valeur ici qui va être âge de l'enquêté
qu'est ce que ça change
à ce stade pas grand chose simplement
je regarde en look fort donc hdv 2003
j'ai un nom un peu plus
qui est indiquée à côté de âge et puis
si toutes vos variable dans votre
enquête s'appelle v 01 02 03 04
comme c'est le cas par exemple pour les
gens qui traitent des enquêtes du type
enquête démographique et de santé
on est bien content d'avoir la
correspondance entre eux l'étiquette est
le nom de la variable si je regarde
si je vais dans le viewer donc pour
rappel à côté du nom de mon tableau je
tape sur la petite icône en forme de en
forme de tableau ce qui me permet
d'afficher le viewer les étiquettes de
variables sont également affichés par
défaut par air studio dans le viewer
alors les étiquettes de variables c'est
juste une information qu'on indique en
plus sur le nom une variable et qui va
être stockés dans mon tableau de données
ça ne change pas la nature de la
variable ça ne modifie en rien c'est
juste une information que l'on indique
en plus on verra la semaine prochaine
on verra la semaine prochaine que les
éthiques
deux variables vous être utilisée par
certains package pour améliorer les
tables automatique qui vont produire ou
pour améliorer les graphiques qui moi
jen ai ri qui maintenant est un peu plus
compliqué ce sont les étiquettes de
valeur alors je suppose que certains
d'entre vous ont des données qui sont
souqués au format texte aux formes csv
ou au format excel
on a vu la semaine dernière pour
importer vos données vous pouvez passer
par forme texte weezer ou femme
excellent et les données que vous allez
importés vont être soit stocké au format
sous forme textuelle ou sous forme de
facteurs ce qui est plus compliqué c'est
pour celles et ceux d'entre vous qui
travaillaient avec sas espèce s ouf ça
parce que si vous voulez importer un
fichier qui vient l'un de ces trois
logiciels là que vous pouvez faire ici
et qui vont passer et on va passer en
fait par une extension qui s'appelle
aveux alors oui pour importer un fichier
stats assez assez facile hein vous avez
juste à donner le nom du fichier mais
dans votre fichier sata en général les
variables est stockée sous une forme
numérique avec étiquette par exemple un
bowie deux mondes on eu neuf veaux ne
sais pas dans ces cas là les données que
vous allez apporter mois d'une classe
particulière elle mois d'une case qui
s'appelle aveux apple est donc ce sont
des données qui sont à qui sont dites
tout labellisés alors je vais vous
montrer un autre exemple si vous tapez
data fécondité ça va
chez qui viennent de couach honneur et
qui s'appelle enfants femmes et à gvt et
2003 enfants femmes et ménages qui sont
des enquêtes de type edf et qui sont des
fichiers que vous auriez importés depuis
sps voyons fichiers enfants
vous avez ici le
est indiqué et vous voyez le sexe de
l'enfant est codé sous la forme de ou un
donc sous forme de nombres si je fais
look faut deux enfants
vous verrez ici
donc vous avez les noms des variables
leur étiquette est ici on nous dit voilà
sexe est codée sur une forme labellisés
c'est donc dbl un monde numérique plus
lbl avec des étiquettes et donc en fait
un veau vasque lui un de vos féminin ce
qui est un petit peu compliqué c'est que
ce type de codage là et pas un codage
naturel pour r c'est quelque chose qui a
été mis en place
l'accord poyry la reproduire le mode de
fonctionnement de ce tas de sas et de
spss mais qui ne correspond pas en fait
à la manière dont air nativement ma
gérer ce type de variables là puisque
huit préfère avoir des facteurs sauf que
quand on travaille sur les données des
enquêtes parfois on veut conserver le
codage d'origine et donc pour celles et
ceux qui vont importer un fichier avec
espèce s stata ou saas les données que
vous a apporté votre côté de cette
manière là c'est compliqué c'est que le
fait qu'il y ait des étiquettes ne veut
pas toujours dire que ça doit être
convertis comme variable catégorielles
parce que parfois dans ses logiciels
d'un peut avoir un un âge qui va être
codé sous la forme 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
et on indique juste une étiquette 99
pour dire ses 99 ou plus alors les
variables qui sont stockés sous cette
forme labellisé en fait ça peut se
manipuler aussi avec le package label de
l'introduire très vite parce que l'on
est sur des sièges qui sont plus
avancées sachez que si vous êtes
confronté à ça et on pourra revenir plus
tard sur une manière plus fine de gérer
ces variables labellisé ici comme le
sexe serait mal comprise si on faisait
de la statistique et scripts yves un
modèle parce qu'elle va être comptée
comme une variable numérique et non pas
comme une variable catégorielles label
def fournit une fonction qui s'appelle
anne labelle tisseyre donc qui marche à
peu près dans 90% des cas
outre
j'ai appelé un label d' sur enfants
d'accord et je vais sauter
blu de données dans un nouvel objet
capelle des voyons ce que ça fait look
port de d ça m'a transformé mais
étiquette qui était labellisé en facteur
en reprenant du coup les étiquettes donc
pour celles et ceux d'entre vous qui
aurez besoin d'apporter des données
stata saas ou espèces
retenez que vous avez le tact jeu label
qui va être manipulé ce type de données
là je vais pas aller plus avant pour le
moment parce que c'est plutôt un outil
plus avancée mais je vous invite
vraiment dans ce cas-là aller d'une part
sur le site d'analyseurs et d'aller lire
en détail le chapitre facteur et vecteur
labellisés pour voir la présentation de
ces vecteurs labellisés qui sont des
choses déjà un peu plus avancé et au
quotidien ce que vous pouvez faire c'est
aussi utiliser la chip chip de label
death alors ça va me permettre de vous
introduire un tout premier élément
qu'est ce qu'on appelle des feuilles de
triche en anglais les cheats chiites
sont des petits documents que vous
pouvez imprimer et à voir à côté de vous
et qui vous permet d'avoir un peu une
synthèse sur un package ou soir certains
sites et aux fonctions vous pouvez y
accéder directement depuis air studio
vous avez euros le menu out est dans le
menu vous avez cicchitto alors vous avez
plusieurs déjà qu'ils sont listés la
première par exemple cr studio et hot
chips si je clique dessus ça vous
à bout
j'ai la chip qui est proche c'est propre
à l'interface des studios et si je
le document obtenu
vous avez un pdf
recto verso qui vous présente tous les
raccourcis clavier de leur studio et qui
vous rappellent aux sauts modo comment
fonctionne l'interface si je
retournerais studio outre assad
chip qui sont directement liste et on
les a par de ras plus tard puisque on
abordera le plagnard en janvier on va
commencer à aborder du type de la
semaine prochaine on va en voir un
certain nombre vous avez aussi un boulot
jichi ce qui vous permet d'accéder à
plus de feuilles de triche sur un plus
grand nombre de paquet
vous avez déjà toutes celles qui sont
développées par l'équipe de hyères sud
jung groupe comme on dit
mais vous avez ensuite
un peu plus bas des contributions qu'ils
ont faites par d'autres utilisateurs
pour d'autres package et vous en avez
une notamment sur le package labase et
d'ailleurs vous voyez c'est vous voyez
puisque c'est moi qui ai développé le
package la belle et vous avez ici la
cchit cheats de la perle
je vous présente où vous pourrez
retrouver toutes les fonctions de
manipulation
des différents
et qu est donc en fait l'idée 1a c'est
que vous n'avez pas toujours besoin de
tout connaître par coeur
là je vous fais juste une présentation
très rapide du package label d' juste
parce que la semaine prochaine on va
revenir sur des ballerines sur les
étiquettes de variables les étiquettes
de valeur je ne vais pas approfondir
pour le moment où je le laisse plus je
voulais juste mentionné pour les
personnes qui travaillent sur sastre
mais sachez en fait que ce qui est
important c'est de savoir pour tel
problème c'est vers tel package que j'ai
besoin d'aller d'aller et ensuite au fur
et à mesure à prendre les éléments et
l'approfondir en fonction de ses besoins
alors je vois
question qui dois-je comprendre que pour
les personnes qui travaillent sur sas
leurs tableaux de données doivent tous
est codé à la base alors que ce n'est
pas nécessaire sur air vous dire non en
fait surface
on choisissait comment vos données sont
codées
ce qui est important à savoir c'est
comment quel format des variables que
l'on va importer
si vous avez 1 1 si vos filles et si vos
données sont dans un fichier sas et que
votre fichier sas est codé soulaf avec
des valeurs numériques à laquelle on a
mis des étiquettes
vous devez savoir que lorsque vous avez
apporté votre fichier sas vos données -
rapportés au format labellisés et vous
aurez donc du coup peut-être de la
transformation à faire mais rien
n'interdit ksu ça d'avoir un fichier qui
est d'abord codé en fait sous une fois
avec des variables qui sont textuelle ou
pouvait avoir un fichier qui est
simplement codec des valeurs numériques
sans étiquette et c'est à vous de savoir
qui est un dictionnaire de codification
fourni apparaît qui vous indiquent la
valeur des différentes étiquettes
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que toute
analyse statistique
en général on passe 90 ou 95% du temps
annie tri donné à les transformer à
l'ére codé et seulement 5 à 10 % du
temps à faire l'analyse proprement dit
y a pas de règle unique les données
qu'on peut récupérer peuvent être en
plein de formats différents
au fur et à mesure des prochaines
sessions on va voir comment les manipule
comme on les transforme en comment est
ce qu'on les records et ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est s'adapter à son cas
particulier
or
ça nous a déjà fait une
bonne grosse cession ou de vie je vais
m'arrêter là
pour le moment ce que je voulais vous
dire c'est la session je risquais pas la
plus marrante on voit vraiment les bases
du langage mais elle est vraiment
essentiel parce que si par la suite je
vous présente du code où il ya un dollar
où il ya des crochets vous avez vous
demandez à quoi ça sert donc il est
vraiment important de connaître les
bases du langage
on va voir au fur et à mesure des
différentes sessions des package qui
vont nous permettre de faciliter et de
manipuler nos tableaux de données et nos
variable de manière de plus en plus
simple la prochaine session la semaine
prochaine elle va être concentrée sur la
statistiques descriptives et on va avoir
deux package en particulier le package
est ch'ti ce qui nous fournit une
interface graphique pour faire assez
facilement des graphiques avec gégé
pelote 2 et en janvier on reviendra plus
en détail sur ggp lot de et comment
aller beaucoup plus loin dans les
graphiques qu'on veut faire et on va
avoir un deuxième paquet djédji this
mari guy thys emma lui permet de faire
très rapidement des tableaux descriptif
avec des tests statistiques
de toute façon c'est l'idée ainsi que
vous ayez un minimum d'éléments pour
pouvoir pendant les congés de noël
commencé à importer vos propres données
a essayé manipuler et de toute façon
par la suite on reviendra sur tout ça
pour vous faire pour et d'arrivée petit
à petit a des choses de plus en plus
complexes voilà retenez bien une chose
les premières ces sont les premières
sessions pardon sont toujours les les
plus laborieuses et plus ça va aller
plus on va pouvoir aller sur des objets
de plus en plus complexes et arriver à
avoir des choses qui sont plus en plus
fluide
surtout ne vous découragez pas il ya un
petit coup d'entrée a démarré avec r
mais je vous assure que d'ici quelques
mois une fois que vous maîtriserez
beaucoup plus cet outil est bien vous
aurez beaucoup beaucoup plus de mal à
vous en passer et il va vite devenir
indispensable
voilà je vous remercie pour tout
remerciement qui sont en train d'un
fluide arrivée sur le tchat
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine du
coup pour une session dédiée à la
statistiques descriptives on va enfin
rentrer dans des choses déjà un petit
peu plus excitante
et puis n'oubliez pas dans deux semaines
on aura une session évacués probablement
pas sur youtube mais je pense sur zoom
ou là on sera sur un mode de discussion
et vous pourrez revenir avec vous même
personnel donc surtout ce que je vous
invite à faire dans les deux prochaines
semaines c'est comment cesse il manipulé
par vous même comme ça dans la session
et facultés de semaine pourrait venir
avec des questions concrètes et on en
aura le temps de réponse d'aller
vraiment sur les problèmes que vous
rencontrez au quotidien merci à vous et
très très bonne fin de soirée